today on the matt wall show a gender
specialist is caught on tape admitting
that girls as young as 12 are having
their breasts chopped off and one
seemingly absurd and unimportant
headline in the news today only further
reveals the brutality and insanity of
this practice i'll explain also voters
in kansas vote to protect the so-called
constitutional right to abortion how
could this have happened in kansas of
all places we'll discuss whoopi goldberg
laments that college graduates are
starving to death because of their
student loans if that's true doesn't it
only further prove that college is a
terrible investment plus the la times
promotes death with dignity also known
as suicide the latest superhero film is
so bad that the studio refuses to even
release it and in our daily cancellation
i respond to continued attacks from a
conservative gun rights activist who
claims that i'm hurting the conservative
movement more than helping is he right
we'll talk about that and much more
today on the matt wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
roe v wade has been overturned and this
battle is now finally leaving dc and
going to the grassroots uh no group in
america is better positioned in 40 days
for life to fight this battle with about
1 million volunteers in a thousand
cities they hold peaceful vigils outside
abortion facilities and they have a
larger presence in blue states where
they're most needed uh california being
their largest state of all some former
abortion facility directors say that
these vigils can cause the abortion
no-show rate to go as high as 75 percent
which of course is detrimental to their
abortion business these law-abiding
vigils have closed many abortion
businesses in america and nearly half of
them were in liberal cities like san
francisco chicago and seattle which are
hardly pro-life areas 40 days for life
is effectively changing hearts and minds
in the grassroots to end abortion you
can check out their locations podcasts
and free magazine at 40daysforlife.com
what we have to always keep in mind is
that the fight for life is not over it
continues and in fact in many ways uh
certainly enters a new phase now after
row and in many ways and even more
important phase as we have this ability
to so directly impact um
the laws governing abortion and to save
lives in the process so for more
information on 40 days for life go to
40daysforlife.com
the news hit like an avalanche yesterday
explosive shocking the most significant
event of the year of the decade of the
century the headlines were published on
cnn nbc news abc news fox all over the
media was trending on every social media
platform people all across this land
were
shouting about it from the rooftops town
criers were announcing it in village
squares the earth-shattering news
reverberated
around the country and down through
history and across space and time
demi lovato
is changing her pronouns
again
as people magazine reports demi lovato
is opening up about her recent pronoun
change about two months after updating
her pronouns on instagram adding she her
alongside the pronouns she'd been using
since last year which are they them
labato recently spoke to host tamera dia
on the spout podcast about what led to
the decision in response to dia asking
lovato to explain the concept of chosen
pronouns like they them the 29 year old
singer songwriter said yeah so
they them is i've actually adopted the
pronouns of she her again
now if that sentence seemed to not make
any sense get ready for a bunch more
sentences that also make no sense here
is lovato explaining her decision in
more detail she of course
updates her pronouns like apple updates
the iphone and i mean both in terms of
the frequency of the updates and the
meaninglessness and redundancy of the
updates but uh here she explains why i
think
i've actually adopted the pronouns of
she her again
so for me
i'm such a fluid person that i don't
really
i don't find that i am
i felt like especially last year my
energy was balanced and my masculine and
feminine energy so that when i was faced
with the choice of walking into a
bathroom and it said women and men i
didn't feel like there was a bathroom
for me
because i didn't feel necessarily like a
woman i didn't feel like a man um i just
felt like a human
and that's what they them is is about
for me it's just about like
feeling human at your core
recently i've been feeling more feminine
well there you have it yesterday we uh
you know yesterday you would have been
banned on every social media platform
for calling demi she
and now you'll be banned if you don't
that's how this works and she's simply
getting in touch with her energy
sometimes her energy is balanced
sometimes her energy tips towards the
feminine sometimes it's masculine
sometimes her energy is low and she
needs to plug into an outlet in the
garage for a while
now obviously none of this makes any
sense at all this is about as credible
as the four humors theory of medicine
popular back in like the middle ages and
back then they believe that a person's
physical health their mental well-being
their personality were all determined by
the balance of blood bile melancholy and
phlegm and those are the four humors and
that theory fell out of favor once the
human body and the brain were better
understood and
uh the and the existence of germs you
know was discovered
though they may have actually been on to
something on second thought as there are
lots of people in our society today who
seem to be predominantly composed of
bile and phlegm
and yet humorism was far more defensible
and credible at the time
because it was the best available theory
to explain these aspects of the human
person based on the information they had
at the time
this gender identity nonsense by
contrast is a superstition invented and
propagated contrary to all of the ample
amounts of evidence that we have on hand
we know that it's nonsense and yet it
has taken over our culture all the same
now i call it nonsense and it is but
that doesn't mean that i can't make
sense of it i do in fact understand what
demi's trying to say
i i think i understand what she's trying
to say better than she does
because this is all simply narcissism
lovato has a
cornucopia of mental illnesses and
various addictions and that certainly
plays a role but mostly
this is the end result of spending
nearly every waking moment of your life
thinking about yourself obsessing over
yourself analyzing yourself and then
analyzing your analysis of yourself
a person who adopts this um i guess
lifestyle choice of narcissism
will quickly conclude that
though she can't make up her mind about
anything and though she by her own
admission doesn't understand herself in
the slightest she is certainly she knows
more interesting more nuanced more
complex more richly and beautifully uh
sketched than most other people in the
world
this is the fundamental narcissistic
assumption that serves as the basis for
everything else when it comes to gender
identity the narcissist feels
you know feels a certain way right as we
all feel different ways and
but they can't actually know whether
other people who share
the same sex feel the same way whether
this is just how people feel
but she assumes
that they don't feel as she does because
she is her you know she's not like
anyone else her feelings are different
and meaningful and profound in ways that
nobody else's are
and so she can't make do with these sex
categories that have proved sufficient
for billions of humans before her she
needs a whole new category
because she is that transcendent she
tells herself in her deluded ego crazed
mind
and this would all perhaps
be something about which we could simply
shake our heads and laugh and
and then move on
if it was a madness consigned to
drug-addled hollywood weirdos but it's
not
you know worst of all of course children
are being recruited into sharing in the
same confusion and self-obsessed misery
as demi lovato and here is where the
lovato story
does in fact have some resonance and
relevance this is why it's actually not
something that we can simply dismiss
there's something important that can be
learned from it and that important thing
is this
demi lovato
is a grown woman technically she is an
adult at least in the chronological
sense of the term
and yet she changes her gender identity
quote unquote every 45 seconds she can't
make up her mind
what she said yesterday may not have any
bearing on today
one minute her deepest truth is that
she's a non-binary pansexual
shape-shifter and the next minute her
truth is something else entirely
now consider
that kids are being drugged and
mutilated their bodies permanently
altered based on their own
gender identity declarations
which are somehow even more fickle and
transmutable and fundamentally
meaningless
everything is fluid everything can be
changed
except the bodies that are butchered and
poisoned based on whatever form of
identity or expression a child has
assumed at that moment
there was a video recently that went
viral which shows someone named kellen
lackhardt
a so-called gender specialist whatever
that is at kaiser permanente in oakland
admitting
that in that program kaiser permanente
children as young as 12 years old
have had their breasts removed 12 years
old listen
yeah i think folks have kind of covered
the blockers and hormones but i'll talk
about surgical care a little bit uh in
terms of masculinizing top surgery i
think 12 is the youngest who's had
surgery through our program um and in
terms of general reconstructive
surgeries we haven't had anyone under
the age of 18 have
phalloplasty or joint plastic but we
have had a few patients
starting
15 i don't think surgery actually
happened until 16 that i've had
vaginoplasty
again girls at the age of 12
not even in high school yet
and they're having body parts
removed we also hear that boys as young
as 16 at an age when at an age when boys
in particular are renowned for being
impetuous and impulsive and
unintentionally self-destructive
and yet at age 16 they're being
castrated
demi lovato is almost 30 years old
and she can't decide what her gender
energy is telling her at any given
moment how in god's name
can we take an adolescent
still over a decade away from their
brain being fully formed how can we take
them seriously when they make their own
declarations
a few days ago the radical lgbt group
stonewall
tweeted that according to quote-unquote
research and they never do specify what
the research is of course but just
research research shows they say
that children as young as two
can recognize their trans identity
two
adults in their twenties and thirties
struggle to understand their identities
apparently
but actual babies still in diapers
sleeping in cribs
can come to realizations that escape
those approaching middle age or older
that's the point we should take away
here
and it's why we actually shouldn't
simply ignore the adult celebrities and
other adults who parade around you know
with their different identity every
other month
far from ignoring it we should be
pointing to them
we should be putting them up on banners
saying here look at this
with the message
leave our kids
out of this
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
there are so many more things to do
during the summer and you want to free
up as much time as possible to enjoy
them so if you're a business owner the
last thing you want to do is sort
through tons of
unqualified candidates resumes when you
could be spending time with family or
doing something to better yourself and
your community which is how i spend my
free time by bettering my community
community service my greatest passion so
that's why if you're like me you need
zip recruiter to find great candidates
they do the work for you and it really
is as simple as that and now you can try
it for free at zippercritter.comwall
zippercutter uses its powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidate with your job you can easily
review the recommended candidates and
invite your top choices to apply it is a
proactive step additionally zip
recruiter has a complete
suite of tools that make it easier to
filter and review and and rate your
candidates as well this is why four out
of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day not to mention zip
recruiter is the number one rated hiring
site so soak up all the summer has to
offer and let zip recruiter do the work
for you ready for the url here here it
is it's zipruter.com walsh that's where
you could try it for free again it's
ziprecruiter.com
w-a-l-s-h zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
all right um lots of conversations now
with another set of twins on the way as
we announced yesterday um one of the big
ones is transportation
and um
i i mentioned that i was
like a day before a couple days before
we found out about the pregnancy we had
just bought a new family vehicle that
fits exactly six people
and um
and then and you know now we've now
we're
expanding to a family of eight
my wife has been she's one of these
people i i honestly i don't understand
it but she's not alone in this she's
just been dead set on not getting a
minivan
and uh she still maintain we talked
about it again last night she still
maintains the delusion
that we can avoid getting any kind of
van
i look i've never bought into the
anti-van propaganda i don't understand
it they're incredibly convenient
they may not be you know as stylish but
um they are practical and i think that
they're quite handsome in their own way
uh my wife is so desperate that she's
wondering she's actually suggested this
can we go to like a chauffeur service
and see if we can
buy one of their old limousines
maybe we can convert an airport shuttle
or something
anything but a but of but a actual you
know passenger van or minivan
it's absurd look the time has come and
that's that's another thing that you
learn and uh it's a big part of
parenting too is just is acceptance
you know and being realistic
and the time has come for the minivan be
still
be not afraid
we are destined for the minivan now the
forces of nature have spoken and it will
be fine it will be okay i believe that
uh this is not so okay though nbc news
is reporting this well actually
it's this is being reported all across
the media uh because they're very
excited about it primary elections in
several states last night
and also some
ballot initiatives and one in particular
is getting a lot of attention attention
is probably understating it the
huffington post had had you know if you
went to their website last night
in huge block letters across the front
page it said earthquake deep red kansas
protects abortion it's an earthquake
and then they tell us in the article
kansans decided to keep abortion
protections in their state constitution
after a tuesday vote a huge win for
pro-choice advocates that will likely
set the tone for what's to come on
abortion rights nationally voters in the
midwest
midwest state voted against the value
them both amendment which was created by
anti-abortion christian groups to strip
protections for abortion care from the
state's constitution the vote which was
held during a primary election had a
historic turnout as high as the 2008
presidential election
the amendment was created in response to
a 2019 kansas supreme court decision
that ruled the state's constitution
fundamentally protects abortion rights
if the value them both amendment had
passed it would have opened the door for
anti-abortion rights lawmakers to pursue
a total abortion ban now obviously
reading for houston post huffington post
and so they're phrasing framing this a
certain way
of course it's anti-abortion rights on
one hand and then pro-choice on the
other we can't be pro-lifers it's not
pro-life and pro-choice we're
anti-abortion rights
so-called
now
um i think the final vote was
something like that was like a 60 40
split or something might have been i
don't know i'm not even sure if the
pro-life vote got up to 40 i think it
was in the 30s
now there's no doubt
in kansas
choosing
not
to um
i mean choosing to
uh
as the headline says protect the
so-called right to abortion
in kansas it is uh it's a surprise it's
also a disappointment and it's pretty
depressing there's no way around that
but it's not that surprising
when you think about it
and you remember that the democrats
first of all have certain built-in
advantages no matter how red the state
is
this isn't uh a rationalization this
isn't a cope it's just true
okay the democrats first of all have the
entire media on
their side
sometimes with the exception of fox news
and sometimes not
so there's the relentless media
propagandizing that's been going on and
has always gone on on every issue
especially abortion and in particularly
you know since the the decision from the
supreme court
abortion is also a billion dollar a
multi-billion dollar industry
and so there's a lot more money there
when it comes to an effort like this
and then
they also have
the advantage really um
of being on the side where they're
exploiting fear
right so you've got the pro-abortion
side
and when it comes to this fight in
kansas and also nationwide the
pro-abortion side they are of course
lying constantly everything they say is
a lie
um
but but they also what they're doing
fundamentally is exploiting people's
fears
they're saying that we're going to end
up in a handmaid's tale that women are
going to be
going to be enslaved and subjugated and
somehow because of the supreme court
decision next thing you know interracial
marriage is going to be illegal i mean
all kinds of fears and it doesn't make
any sense they're just throwing
everything they can against the wall to
see what sticks
and then especially on an on an
individual level
if a woman is pregnant then all they
have for the woman is fear fear
fear okay here's here's all the horrible
things that will happen you you have you
have no choice you have to go get an
abortion
your life will be over if you don't
that's what the pro-abortion side is
doing exploiting fear
um
on the pro-life side on the other hand
we're calling people to something
greater right to uh calling them to
respect the dignity of human life
calling people to
virtue
to moral rightness
that's what we have
and just it's a it's a reality of human
nature that
exploiting fear is a lot easier to do
and it can often be much more potent
and it can often be much more effective
it's one of the sad realities of human
nature
i mean we have
goodness on our side we have the light
of truth on our side
we have love and dignity and joy and we
have all of that on the pro-life side
and
and and that is all of course better
than what they have on the pro-abortion
side but when it comes to
motivating people
especially in mass
exploiting fear can be a lot more
powerful and so that's what
the left has found and then there's also
this too keep in mind
um the wording of this initiative
is pretty confusing
i mean they really couldn't have awarded
it any worse truly so here's what the
ballot said so when the people in kansas
went to vote here's what the ballot said
okay
because kansans value both women and
children the constitution of the state
of kansas does not require government
funding of abortion and does not create
or secure a right to abortion
to the extent permitted by the
constitution of the united states the
people through their elected state
representatives and state senators may
pass laws regarding abortion including
but not limited to laws that account for
circumstances of pregnancy resulting
from rape or incest or circumstances of
necessity to save the life of the mother
okay so that was the the initiative that
the um kansans were faced with yesterday
a yes vote is the pro-life vote on that
so
a yes vote would say
that there is no constitutionally
protected right to abortion so in a way
a yes is a no you're saying yes
there is no constitutional right to
abortion
and then if you vote no there is a
constitutionally protected right to
abortion
now it's not too difficult to figure out
how to interpret this
but it's still too difficult for a
ballot initiative
especially when you consider that on the
left this is whether we're talking about
abortion or any other issue
along with exploiting fear
they also exploit confusion and fear and
confusion are very much related they are
they are you know two sides of the same
coin they're they're cousins at least
first cousins
uh people fear what they what they're
confused about what they don't
understand
and this is what the left always does
they obfuscate they confuse
they want you kind of lost in the hazy
mist where you don't know exactly which
way is up and what's going on
so i have a ballot initiative that's
confusingly worded is always going to
help the
the left more than it's gonna help the
right
all those things together is how you end
up with what happened in kansas although
again it's still
a
quite sad state of affairs all right
next we'll go to the view
speaking of a sad state of affairs
whoopi goldberg has been on a roll
lately with incredibly bad takes and
here's her latest on student loan
forgiveness listen
if you have worked your behind off
you've tried to move yourself up the
ladder you talk about people can't get
gas they can't buy food they can't put
their children through through any kind
of college that's because they're paying
off these freaking student debts
um so
here's my point about this because
we hear this a lot
about why we need student loan
forgiveness because you've got all these
college graduates and they've got
student loan
debt and they can't afford gas they
can't afford food they can't afford to
live not because of inflation's got
nothing to do with inflation don't blame
inflation don't blame uh the biden
administration nothing to do with them
it's because of these student loan debts
and if it wasn't for that then they'd be
able to afford all these things
and yet
the people who make these claims
that college graduates don't have
they don't have jobs good enough to
afford them the basic necessities of
life
the people who make that claim will
still insist that college is a necessary
and worthwhile investment
i mean you just if that's true what you
just said
we've got college graduates who can't
even afford food
apparently we're not able to get a job
with their degree
that was good enough to ensure that they
can survive
then wouldn't that putting student loan
the student loan debt problem aside for
a moment doesn't that show that the
college degree is a really bad
investment
if you can't even you can't even survive
you can't get a you can't get a survival
level job
after getting the degree
but they never take it that far
they never connect those dots
everything when we talk about student
loans
everything they say about it would seem
to indicate
and much of what they're saying is has
at least some truth to it
um
except that there's the disconnect
because what they're saying would really
seem to indicate that among other things
uh the college degree is a is oftentimes
a bad investment
and it's just not working out
for many people
they were sold a bill of goods
they were that's all
the primary reason people they went to
college in the first place because they
were told that they go to college
they're going to get a good job
afterwards and it hasn't played out that
way
and it hasn't been playing out that way
for years
for a huge number of college graduates
so maybe that means we should reassess
our um
you know habit
our strategy of funneling everybody into
college directly out of high school
especially that part of it the directly
after high school part
it's crazy to me that we can't at least
agree on this
i know i'm never going to be able to get
most people to agree with and understand
that college in general is is
unnecessary for a large number of people
like that's um
at least right now i'm not gonna be able
to convince most people of that but can
we
can we not at least agree
that there is no reason to go into
college directly out of high school
i've been saying this forever i can say
it till i'm blue in the face it's just
there's no reason to do it
like there might be a few exceptions to
every rule the exception here might be i
don't know if you have a if you have an
athletic if you have a full ride
athletic scholarship
um
even if you don't have a full-ride
athletic scholarship for if you
for athletics
if one of the main reasons you want to
go to college is because you're an
athlete you want to play sports
at the college level then that could be
you know that's that's a pretty good
reason maybe to go right into college
out of high school
but
that's the only
possible exception that i can conceive
of for everybody else
nothing bad can happen if you leave high
school and then just
get a job uh just live for a couple of
years do whatever
live in the world for a couple of years
there's nothing bad that can happen
you're not in a in a race you want to
play athletics and that does put you at
a little bit of a of a
it does put you in a race right but
outside of that you're not in a race
even if you want to become uh even if
you know that you probably want to be a
doctor or lawyer or something like that
well you're going to be in school for
years anyway
a couple years isn't going to make or
break you
so you spent a couple of years you you
leave high school spend a couple years
in the real world you get a job you make
some money
um
and worst case scenario worst case
scenario is that you're behind by a
couple of years but you have money in
the bank now but behind who who are you
racing
now this is just this is just uh life
now they're not you're not racing
anybody
well i know why the university system
doesn't encourage this approach
right they don't encourage kids to take
a couple of years off and i don't even
like the way that's phrased take a
couple years off
you're not taking off
i'm not saying that you should leave
high school and then just sit at home
and do absolutely nothing for two or
three years i wouldn't encourage that no
you're gonna do something
you're not off at all in fact you were
off before now you're on you're in
you're on you're in you're in the real
world
and the reason the university system
does not encourage this is because they
realize
that if these kids come out of high
school and then go out into the real
world for a few years that a large
portion of them are never going to
go to college because they're going to
discover
that they don't need college
to do what they want to do with their
lives
for for many kids during that time
they're going to figure out what they
want to do with their lives and most
kids out of high school have no idea
and then you give them a couple years
they're going to start to figure it out
and many of them are going to discover
that their career path their vocation
doesn't require a college degree so
they're not going to go and the
university system is going to lose out
on all that money
and that's why they want the kids they
want them in college right away before
they know what hit them
before they have time to think about it
and they want you to realize that you
don't need the degree after you've
already paid for it
because there are no refunds they don't
want you to realize that before you pay
for it
so that's the universal system i can
understand from a pure profit-driven
profit motivated perspective why they
don't want you to leave high school and
and go out into the real world but al
everybody else i i that's where i don't
get it
especially parents who pressure their
kids to go right from high school to
college it's crazy to me
you are actively working against your
child's own best interests
doesn't make any sense all right so this
is quite a morbid and sad story about um
what the la times calls and what all
pro-euthanasia people call
euphemistically death with dignity and i
saw this circulating
yesterday online this is uh the headline
is one last trip gabriella walsh's
decision to die
and celebrate life on her own terms
and uh it continues with the story it
says gabriella walsh knew she wanted to
die on a saturday if she'd settled on
july 16th dressing that morning in a
flower crown and a t-shirt with a
picture of a dragonfly an image that had
comforted her in recent weeks she took a
deep inhale from a bottle of lavender
oil and listened to a playlist of c
sounds
earlier in the morning friends and
family nuzzled up against her in bed
rest easy they told her and keep
wandering i just feel like i'm going on
a trip she said calmly
within two hours she would drink a fatal
dose of medications prescribed under
california's death with dignity law
which allows some terminally ill
patients to request drugs to end their
lives
the option had given her profound
comfort in her final weeks as had
knowing that in the end she'd have
jack barcegon the registered nurse who
managed her hospice care and jill shock
a death doula at either side of her bed
a death doula
my god
now
we should be uh
very wary about this idea
that dignified death is suicide we
should just be wary of it we should
reject it
uh we should passionately reject this
idea that the the most dignified way to
die
is through suicide
and of course the implication here is
because she's this was a woman who's
terminally ill with cancer
and she chose death with dignity which
was suicide implication is that
if she had not committed suicide and and
allowed the cancer to kill her then that
is that's an undignified death
yes we should absolutely reject that
drinking poison
given to you by a doctor
is
dignified
and even if you can't grasp like the
moral argument against an individual
committing suicide as a means of
escaping suffering
if you can't grasp the more the more
argument then you should at least be
able to understand
the other great objection to euthanasia
which is that it further subverts and
perverts the medical profession
and
because doctors should not be in the
position
of killing people
and i know that we kind of take it for
granted these days that doctors kill and
harm people because that's what so many
doctors do and their billion dollar
industries erected around this
with abortion with the the gender
industry
killing harming mutilating drugging
poisoning like doctors do that quite a
bit these days
but but they shouldn't that's not what
medicine is
that's why traditionally the hippocratic
oath is do no harm
i mean the idea that
poison just the simple the simple
concept of calling poison
medicine
well no medicine treats medicine is
supposed to treat and heal
you have something wrong with you and
you take medicine to treat it to heal it
so
poison
if medicine is poisoned what is the
disease that it's treating
life
i guess so
euthanasia tells us that life itself is
a disease
and it can be treated
with the medicine of a poison that kills
somebody
one other point about this
euthanasia especially under the
euphemism of death with dignity is
what you get from a death phobic culture
this is our fear of death our refusal to
acknowledge and grapple with the reality
of death that produces this and i know
it seems kind of paradoxical it seems
counterintuitive because um why would
you advocate for death why would you
advocate for suicide if you're afraid of
death
why would you be pro-death and yet
afraid of it
how can you be pro-death and rejecting
it at the same time
well because
this is an attempt to hide from the
reality of death
you know
you hear even in the story there that
the suicidal person is saying oh i'm
just going on a trip
and you have a death doula
and you're taking
medicine
this is actually again it's a paradox
because you are directly killing
yourself but it is actually the fear of
death or rejection of death the um
unwillingness to accept the reality of
death and of our own mortality
what we want and the reason why people
support euthanasia really is because
they want to see death as something that
we can contain
that we can take control over that we
can have mastery over
you often hear of the uh of the
euthanasia victim
that they were dying on their own terms
these are my terms
i'm gonna do it my way
as if they have taken as if they have
taken control over life and death
oh yeah the grim grim reaper has no
purchase here
i'm gonna do it my way
but that's just not how it works death
is not something that we can control
it is an ever-present reality
it's something that we should
accept a reality that we should accept
rather than in effect you know using
death to as as as a means of escaping it
all right
um here's a story you may have heard
something about this this is the latest
from the new york post it says a
transgender cheerleader kicked out of a
texas college for allegedly choking a
teammate
denies that there was any physical
altercation and intends to sue actually
avery chanel medlock
insisted
okay we've got the pronoun issue here as
it's written so i'm going to try to
correct it as we go along um avery
chanel medlock 25 insisted his side of
the story wasn't heard before he was
slapped with a 500 criminal citation and
kicked off of the cheer team for
allegedly assaulting another cheerleader
on july 24th at
ranger college medlock told the post
there was no physical contact at all i
was just trying to talk it out as an
adult medlock whose legal name is avery
chanel satchel claims that teammate
carly jones got upset
when
she refused to buy her a vape
with the way the pronunciation are
switched around i'm this gets even more
confusing
so
who was
who refused to buy who a vape i don't
even know now medlock later went to
carly's room to apologize but an
argument ensued rather than an assault
as alleged
medlock's teammate then called her
father who called the police the athlete
said that she was then escorted off of
university grounds and booted from
ranger college cheer team she isn't he
the guy okay it's just
it makes it impossible to understand
anything of course uh when we're doing
this pronoun thing
uh messages seeking comment from ranger
college cheerleading coach nicholas
turner university officials were not
immediately returned
medlock says if i would have assaulted
her i'd be in jail
and yet the police say that there was an
assault
okay so that's the story is that that
was originally a story that this
cheerleader who is who is a male but
identifies as a female is on the
cheerleading squad uh physically
assaulted in fact choked
a an actual female on the team and the
original story was that he reacted that
way because the female
said you know remarked about the fact
that he has a penis and therefore isn't
a woman and he responded violently the
father was called the police were called
the police say that there was an assault
that occurred
and um even though they're just slapping
the assailant with a minor fine about
you know about on par with what you get
for a parking violation but the assault
did happen
now he's coming out and saying oh no it
never happened at all
a couple of points here first of all
we're gonna put some of the the pictures
up on the screen that are in the new
york post article and we've seen and
anytime the story comes up on social
media these are the pictures attached to
it
and you can see this is the uh the trans
cheerleader
and you can see
okay there's another one there
just filtered and photoshopped to death
look this one right here is come on
it looks like he it looks like he peeled
off somebody else's face and put it on
um when you
when you have to do that
okay then maybe that should tell you
something
like the pictures that are being
circulated of this guy are
these are not pictures these are cartoon
drawings that's not what he looks like
at all
but also maybe more importantly the
violence is not a surprise at all
as the existence of men in these spaces
in women's sports and women's bathrooms
men claiming the label of womanhood for
themselves in any context at all
you know this is a form of violence
already i'm going to use the left's
framing against it here because they
like to say that everything is violence
speech is violence silence is violence
uh sometimes violence though is in
violence
but everything else is violence
well i would say that this is violence
even before you get to the physical
assault before the physical assault
happens it is violence because
when men intrude into these spaces and
they appropriate female identities
it is an invasion it's an intrusion it
is a a robbery
stealing privacy stealing a woman's
identity stealing opportunities all of
that
and it comes with an implicit and often
explicit threat
of social shaming
of loss of job loss of status
you know if you if a woman protests it
so when the man shows up whether he says
it out loud or not then oftentimes he
does say it out loud but even if he
doesn't the the implied threat to all of
the women
is that you better go along with this
you better let them into your spaces you
better you better sacrifice
privacy on the altar of uh of this man's
ego and if you don't bad things are
going to happen to you
so that is violence in and of itself
and then it shouldn't be a surprise when
you have this
sort of
implied threat
that always accompanies the man as he
enters into these female spaces it
shouldn't be a surprise when he actually
lashes out violently
and in particular because of the uh
because of the sense of entitlement
that's that's encouraged
i mean these guys have already been told
by society you can do whatever you want
the only thing that matters
is your comfort level the only thing
that matters
is how you feel that's all that matters
that should be your number one number
two one through ten list of priorities
it's all about you
and so you
put all those things together and you
have a recipe for actual physical
violence against women so this is not a
surprise at all
one other thing to note sad news today
i'm afraid from the new york post it
says the dc comics film batgirl will be
completely shelved by warner brothers a
top hollywood source told the post that
means it won't hit theaters or the
streaming service
hbo max fans will not see this movie at
all
uh the reportedly 70 million movie which
actually had a budget closer to 100
million was doing test screenings for
audiences in anticipation of a late 2022
debut and it would rank among the most
expensive cinematic casts off
ever so this is what what's happening
here is that they made this film batgirl
and they spent 100 million dollars on it
and now they're just it's so bad that
they're simply not going to release it
at all nobody will ever see it that's
how bad it is
which i find quite hilarious
uh and also of course it's a bad movie
it's batgirl
there is no version of that film that
can be good it is guaranteed to be
terrible
no big surprise that your investment was
wasted
and like i've said before with these
female superheroes
it doesn't even
begin to work when you have a female
superhero if the character doesn't have
actual superpowers it's absurd enough
already
when you give the superhero
god-like powers and everything but
when it's when it's in the batman
universe
and there are no actual superpowers
and now i'm supposed to take it
seriously that this that this
girl
with no superpowers is going around
beating up bad guys
in her leather bat outfit
so you can't do the only way that these
superhero films
can claim any kind of artistic
credibility
um the only way that they can be
elevated
right is if they go with the gritty you
know we're gonna go gritty realistic and
that's what they do with the batman
films well you can't do that when it's a
when you've got some 23 year old woman
you know 112 pounds going around beating
up a bunch of a
bunch of bad guys just doesn't work
so 100 million dollars wasted
pretty great stuff let's get to the
comment section
who makes a twitter mob fly off the
handle with rage
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
congrats on the twins matt says dizzy
unknown will the dw give us a last man
standing type sitcom based on your life
should you have twin girls
maybe get tim allen to play a grandpa it
would be a hit just saying uh
you know we really should do something
with tim allen he's seems to be right up
our alley and he's been
canceled of course and he was kicked off
of the buzz lightyear the woke buzz
lightyear film that just came out so
maybe this is it i don't know it's not a
bad idea candace says okay matt
from where do the stats come that you're
using to assert that black people are
more likely to commit violent crimes
than white people
how do crimes get counted by crimes
committed criminal activity reported
criminal charges filed or convictions
minus successful appeals slash
overturned convictions because if the
stats rely on police reporting and or
court convictions and the claim is af
afro-featured people are more targeted
arrested charged and convicted by law
than folk with light skin
due to aesthetic appearance and false
assumptions rather than behavioral
observations well then obviously the
stats will reinforce the false
assumptions right
for me personally i tend to get uneasy
when a strange unkept 25 to 50 year old
white male is near me especially if
wide-eyed because i think mass shooter
but i don't call him out or anything
like that
okay well
uh where do the stats come from i find
fair question they come from the fbi
these are fbi crime statistics which
consistently show year over year over
year that black offenders account for
over 50
of homicides which is a vastly
disproportionate share okay i mean
vastly disproportionate
now
um
and that's not just i mean the fbi
crimes did you go the fbi
website and find those crime statistics
but but in any crime any anywhere you go
like go anywhere else wherever your
preferred source of information is on
crime statistics they're all going to
tell you that
now if you're suggesting that there are
hundreds of thousands of white murderers
running around out there who are let off
scot-free and never pursued because of
their race
and um if only they would be arrested
too then it would even out the
statistics well if that's what you're
suggesting or
or uh theorizing
i'm gonna need even like one single
little shred of the smallest bit of
evidence to support that
but you don't have that
do you because it's absurd
okay
so we we can talk about why this
disparity in violent crime exists
that's a good conversation to have and
we're gonna get into the collapse of the
family and many other things but
um it's an interesting and worthy
conversation
but it does exist
it just simply does
that's a fact
okay
and your fears that just some that any
random 25 to 50 year old white male you
come across as a mass shooter
that actually is
statistically unreasonable
because the uh proportion of mass
shooters among the white popul white
male population is so vanishingly small
that you may as well walk around worried
that
you know a meteor is going to fall on
your head
and also i should note that white males
do not account for a disproportionate
amount of mass shootings either so look
these are all the facts these are all
the statistics and they say what they
say that's it
so you
that's my point you
when it comes to interpreting when it
comes to
explaining
all these things that that's where we
can have a more in-depth conversation
and people can have different points of
view and it becomes a bit more nuanced
and it's a larger conversation but the
starting point of the statistical facts
well those are this just simply are what
they are and
that's it
um
g hibiscus says uh hey matt i just heard
you were having another set of twins
congrats on that sweet daddy and this
really
is what y'all get for saying one kid is
easy
fair analysis that is a fair point
scott says matt what do i win if i can
correctly guess the names of your new
set of twins well there's nothing to
guess right now because we have no idea
what the names are you could suggest
some names i mean i'm open to that i
hope it's a suggestion we take the name
question all the way down to the wire
this is what we've done with every kid
we'll be like five hours from birth and
uh we're going through the alphabet
that's what we end up doing is just
going through the alphabet abc and
listing every
name that starts with that letter as we
go down and land on something um so
we don't know but again open to
suggestions
jenna and i know i'm gonna regret saying
that i'm open to suggestions on that but
i just said it jennifer says matt are
you rooting for one gender or another
well
uh they're looking identical so either
our family is gonna be four boys and two
girls or four girls and two boys
so there's very high stakes here one
team or the other is going to be vastly
outnumbered here um as for which i
prefer
i'll take
whatever god blesses us with there's
pros and cons either way that's the
truth um boys are they're
less emotional they're a little bit
easier to understand they're less prone
to random emotional outbursts
uh they're
you know rough and tumble they're a lot
of fun you can pick them up and toss
them around
girls though
on the other hand are
now they are more prone to random
confusing emotional outbursts and all
those kinds of things but they're also
much much more helpful around the house
than boys are
boys are basically useless around the
house that's the truth
like my nine-year-old daughter
can she can
you know she can she likes to with our
two-year-old she likes to put the
two-year-old to bed oh can i put her to
bed
sure go ahead
so um girls are also less likely to
break things including uh their own
bones and limbs and objects around the
house so there's you know
there are unique challenges and joys
with either one and so it's hard to
really
root for one or the other
and finally liam says why do you get so
mad or ban someone every time people
question how the sweet baby gang started
well you are tempting fate by even
asking that question liam
and today it was the wrong gamble
because you're banned
leave
and never return but thanks for
listening
you know this summer we launched daily
wire plus which is our ever expanding
hub for all things daily wire including
movies shows podcasts prageru kids
content which is coming soon and last
but not least the formidable intellect
of jordan peterson in addition to his
archive of content you can also find his
brand new podcast and lecture series on
daily wire plus where even
re-contextualizing some of his works
like his genesis lecture series genesis
has a
worldwide phenomenon that offered a
compelling perspective on the biblical
stories that we thought we knew well now
available in a readable collection with
brand new illustrations jordan
peterson's lecture series explores the
psychological significance of the
biblical stories in the book of genesis
and how they affect all of us to this
day to watch and read the series and
access the entire archive of jordan
peterson content head to
dailywireplus.com
and become a member today that's
dailywireplus.com right now now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
for our daily cancellation we head back
to history class a subject that uh kids
learn every year in public school which
means that they never really learned the
subject at all of course uh it falls
then to others sometimes it even falls
to podcasters without a college degree
to pick up the slack that's what i tried
to do over the weekend and then on my
show on monday as we discussed the issue
of slavery no need to rehash all of my
points my primary goal was to
communicate the fact that the story of
slavery is much larger much deeper much
wider ranging than the version they tell
in schools in the media in hollywood
as i observed white people were slaves
also millions of them were in fact the
trade in white slaves especially in
north africa but even in north america
was big business
it's a fact an important one
but not everybody agreed which isn't to
say that they disagreed with the facts
that i was sharing you can't disagree
with facts you can either choose to
acknowledge them or not
but facts don't care about your feelings
or your acknowledgement it turns out no
the critics disagree now with the
indisputable facts about slavery that i
discussed
but rather with the fact that i was
discussing them they felt that it was
horrible nazi-esque uh it was racist
white supremacist to even hint that
there might be more to the slavery issue
than the white enslavement of black
africans in the west from the 17th 19th
centuries
as mentioned on the show on monday the
critics were mostly on the left but not
solely
maj toure who's a well-known gun rights
activist was quite vigorous and
relentless in his criticism he said that
my statements about slavery were dumb
reductive counterproductive horrible
[ __ ] his word and many other things
he said that i was damaging the inroads
that conservatives had made with the
black community
and he continued in this vein in many
tweets and videos railing against me for
mentioning that white people were slaves
so finally on monday he appeared on my
friend jason whitlock show on the blaze
to further explain his point of view i
watched the segment and i have to tell
you that after listening to him if
anything i understand his criticisms
less than i did before so let's go
through this together listen
first um i i did like what is a woman um
i think matt is usually spot on on
certain things it's this is similar to a
lot of um conservatives i'm very
critical
it's almost like if we're going into the
tactic room right
what does this actually prove i just did
an interview um and you know we
discussed a guy said well you know what
would be wrong with all lives matter and
i'm like well there's nothing
technically wrong with it if you thought
that you should have said it before blm
said black lives matter it's just what
it is and everybody knows i don't really
bang with blm as an organization but the
phrase in the redec
redactive you know reductive component
well this is perhaps beside the point
but for the record
lots of us were saying all lives matter
before blm came along
that was and still is the central motto
of the pro-life movement we didn't steal
it from them they stole it from us
we didn't start saying all lives matter
when blm came along we kept saying it
we were told though that we had to stop
saying it because somehow left-wing
black activists were the only ones
allowed to decide and declare which
lives mattered
but but even if we had started saying it
only after blm was formed so what it's
still true
and besides this is meant to be a
response and corrective to blm militants
who in fact as is obvious do not believe
that all lives matter
the blm movement is a black supremacist
movement and that's why all lives matter
was and still is a necessary rejoinder
to it
by the way maj is the founder of an
organization called black guns matter
he sells t-shirts with the phrase on it
so maj were you saying black guns matter
before black lives matter came along
something tells me that you weren't yet
you can use the blm slogan to sell
shirts and advocate for gun rights but
we can't use it to advocate for the
fundamental worth and value of human
life in general
it's reductive for us to say all lives
matter but not for you to say black guns
matter
interesting
let's continue
and let me be clear
if we're trying to make inroads into
black communities these types of takes
that have nothing to do with anything
yeah well i gotta i gotta stop you there
again very briefly we'll back up and
play the whole clip but
uh he says my take had nothing to do
with anything
well that's not true i mean it had
something to do with history uh with
truth with the facts of the world that
shaped human civilization it had
something to do with the racial
grievance industry which trades on the
idea that slavery in america was a
unique and unprecedented evil when in
fact it was not it was an evil but not
unique or unprecedented uh it had
something to do with lots of different
things it had something to do with a
book that i read and i wanted to talk
about it had something to do with what
happened to be on my mind at that moment
all of these are perfectly fine
rationales for sharing my thoughts
the criticism that maj is offering here
is by far the most useless boring and
exhausting form of criticism and also
perhaps the most common on the internet
that's why i find it so irritating uh
this is the you know why are you talking
about this why talk about this and not
something else i i don't care about this
why are you discussing it it's that
whole routine it's a totally worthless
critique it really is just because you
don't find a subject important or
relevant or worthy of consideration
doesn't mean that nobody should ever
talk about it
i don't have to explain to you why i
want to discuss something
i don't have to seek your permission
ahead of time
if you don't care about the subject or
find it important then keep moving keep
scrolling no one's forcing you to
participate in a conversation that you
apparently find so unworthy of your
attention
it just would never i'd never do this to
people i never go into go to someone
else's page or listen to their podcast
or whatever and then say why are you
talking about this why this and not not
this other thing over here
it's just the criticism makes no sense
so we're not off to a good start but
let's continue
these types of takes that have nothing
to do with anything
kind of like just gives extreme leftists
more of a tool to utilize against us and
what i mean by that is
if i'm a person in the middle let's say
i'm a democrat and i'm not the extreme
lefty i think a lot of these guys are
making moves that are in
like reactionary to what extreme lefties
do
that doesn't advance conservative
movements
to people that may be in the middle in a
democratic city
so we say a thing and then an extreme
leftist packages and says see they're
minimizing your ability or the the
history of the transatlantic slave trade
now matt may have not been trying to do
that i'm talking about from a tactical
and strategic standpoint the left
dominates urban and black america
because they understand pr and messaging
way better than the right does simple
and plain they have to because they
don't have many facts sorry they just
don't so they have to be very good at
smoking mirrors and lying in pr because
that's what a lot of public relations or
perception and reality is
this and and i think maybe matt's
following maybe took it a little too
they got a little sensitive about it but
it's always
one step in the right direction with a
lot of conservatives and then we say
something that makes the job of my job a
lot more difficult because it's like
damn that sounds like you trying to
downplay the role and that's what every
extreme leftist is going to do and so
from a strategic and tactical standpoint
this does not spread conservative values
or make the job better we keep going
with this facts don't care about your
feelings concept and how has that been
working out for us by not expressing any
type of empathy first
uh well it's worked out pretty well
actually thank you for asking refusing
to be emotionally blackmailed by
dishonest manipulative cry bullies has
been a tremendously
successful approach and it's one of the
reasons why the guy who coined that
phrase is one of the most influential
thinkers in the country and the company
he co-founded is making inroads into the
culture in ways that nobody else on the
right ever has certainly including our
friend maj but let's back it up a bit
maj accuses me of being reactionary
right reacting to the left and yet his
entire critique centers around the the
left and how he thinks we should react
to it
well we can't say that the radical left
will use it against us
he suggests that the black community
will be easily duped by the dishonest
talking points of the left and so that
we should calibrate our approach
accordingly
he does allow generously that perhaps i
wasn't trying to minimize the
transatlantic slave trade maybe i wasn't
but he says that the left will accuse me
of doing that
so let me see if i have this right
you're worried that the left will accuse
me of something dishonestly and so your
strategy is to head them off at the pass
and accuse me of it first
now maj you're a smart guy i know that
you're not dumb enough to believe that i
was minimizing the slave trade
or indeed that any rational person would
ever do that
suggesting that i even might have tried
to minimize the slave trade by talking
about other forms of slavery it's like
suggesting that i might be minimizing
kidney cancer by talking about lung
cancer
it's an incoherent ridiculous
fundamentally dishonest accusation and
you know it
everybody
understands that slavery in america
was a terrible evil
nobody suggests otherwise
everybody agrees that it was bad which
is all the more reason why perhaps at
this point it might be time to expand
the conversation to talk about the forms
of slavery that lots of people don't
even know existed
we talk about slavery all the time in
america the american form of slavery
kids learn about it
they make movies about it activists
scream about it it is a constant ever
present historical reality nobody has
forgotten it nobody could ever forget it
everyone knows that it happened and
everyone agrees that it was unspeakably
evil and it should not have happened
everybody everybody
okay
which is which is good right it's good
that everybody knows it happened and
everyone thinks it's bad
success on that subject
should that be the end of the slavery
conversation or might we at this
juncture
widen the lens a little bit
to try to get a look at the fuller
picture
now it seems that you would prefer that
we keep the lens narrow
and rather than admitting that your
preference is your preference you try to
farm it off to the radical left claiming
that you're only telling me what they
will say
and sure yeah the left does say that any
discussion of historical atrocities not
centered around the plight of black
africans in america is inherently racist
they do say that
and they're wrong
you're saying it too and you are also
wrong
now you talk about tactics and strategy
you use the word interchangeably like
they mean the same thing they don't
strategy is your overall approach to the
war tactics are the maneuvers the
individual steps specific actions that
you take and service to that strategy
i'm not splitting hairs here i mean the
difference is actually important because
you say that we should avoid certain
uncomfortable truths strategically and
also tactically but which is it is is
this our strategy is our strategy to
abandon the truth seed the entire
historical and racial narrative to the
left in hopes of outflanking them to
their left
if so then sure i mean only talking
about slavery or racial injustice in
terms of the left demands is a good
tactic
but it's a tactic and a strategy that
loses the war it is a surrender
see my goal my strategy and my tactic
are actually all the same for me
um because i'm a simple man so for me
it's the truth
i just say what is true
if i say something and it's not true
you know if i inadvertently say
something i'm incorrect about what i'm
saying and you have a counter-argument
that proves that it's incorrect then i
will listen
and uh and if you can convince me that
it was incorrect then i'll change my
point of view but if you admit that i'm
saying the truth
and you still criticize me for saying it
well i'm just not interested in that
critique i'm really not
if one person is saying the truth and
the other person doesn't want to hear
the truth whatever their reason
the problem lies entirely 100 percent
with the latter so you say what about
all the people who don't want to hear
about this that's their problem
that's not my problem
there is something wrong with them that
they don't want to hear
a truth
and in this case they don't want to hear
a truth about the way the entire world
worked for thousands of years
that's their problem not mine
as for me you know i think what our
culture lacks most of all is not empathy
it's not feeling it's not pity or
patronizing pats on the head but truth
and anyone who stands against truth
or insists that the truth be muffled or
silenced or withheld
is today i'm afraid to say
maj
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by jeff tomblin our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022